meanwhile researchers hope plasma from
coronavirus survivors may help cure
seriously ill patients we should note
that plasma therapy for the virus is
still experimental and clinical trials
are underway single medical
correspondent dr. tara Narula spoke with
families who turned to this type of
therapy when all else failed we really
didn't expect him to to decline so
rapidly the way you did I didn't even
know he was going into the coma so I
couldn't even see doctors at Orlando
Health tried a cocktail of drugs
including hydroxychloroquine to help
save fifty two-year-old husband and
father kevin raffle but days passed with
no improvement racing right here she
broke down a couple of times just crying
and she says I just want my daddy home
after hearing about the promise of
plasma therapy it became his wife
Stacey's mission to find a plasma donor
and she quickly found a match on
Facebook three days after the
transfusion Kevin woke up from a
medically induced coma he's crying he's
now able to talk and is expected to go
home today
the treatment gives sick patients the
antibody rich blood plasma from
recovered patients to help fight the
virus one plasma donation can
potentially treat up to three infected
patients we need to do the clinical
trials to know when it is and how is it
dr. Arturo Casa de ball has been
studying antibodies for over three
decades and says while more research
needs to be done it shows promise and
history is on its side the first Nobel
Prize in medicine was given for the
discovery that you could treat a disease
with antibodies she was to use in the
1918 flu epidemic more recently it's
beneath you student it's ours our break
in 2003 he says timing plays a huge role
in the success of a transfusion we think
you can get
much more bang for the buck if you treat
people early brothers Craig Jason and
Jeff worse we're not just fearing the
worst but preparing for it after they're
76 year old dad Henry was hospitalized
for over three weeks we're down to the
time we're asked to say possibly say
goodbye and even looking for skin
replaces and what the policies are out
there in this period similar to the
rifle family they turned to Facebook for
help in finding a plasma donor were you
all nervous at any point about trying
something that was so experimental no
our dad was was headed in a downward
spiral this was one of our only shots
Craig's high school friend turned out to
be their Savior
it can't be more rewarding whether you
know the recipient or not you're doing a
good thing you're saving a life and
shortly after the plasma therapy their
dad slowly began to show signs of
improvement and over this weekend news
that he could be coming home soon
how do you think your father is going to
feel when he hears about the tremendous
effort that you put forth to save him
proud I think that's the only word I
could think of we acted as one I mean I
think he's gonna be proud of that and
dr. taryn urilla joins us now Wow Tara
these are such encouraging stories but
not everyone is as lucky as these
families or have been in finding donors
why is it so difficult to find them well
Anthony before this pandemic there
really wasn't a fully functional system
in place that's evolving real-time one
of the other issues is that the demand
really outweighs the supply we have lots
of people who are still sick still
recovering so the situation will
definitely be different in a month or
two and then we've talked a lot about
the testing logistically in order to
donate you need to have that documented
positive test and then that documented
negative test and we know how hard it's
been to get testing at all for any any
part of the your illness and lastly if
you want to donate to somebody that is a
friend or a family member you also have
to have the same blood types that has to
be matched all right some progress
though Tara thank you so much